a lot of new things happening in the DC
EU today earlier we got our first
official look at Shazam if you want to
check out my breakdown video of it you
can in the link above and today we also
received a leaked video of Kristen Wiig
playing cheetah on the set of Wonder
Woman 1984 before we get started be sure
to subscribe to my channel so you could
stay up to date on Wonder Woman 1984
this is the first time that we've
received any sort of footage regarding
Kristen Wiig character cheetah as you
can see here she's in normal street
clothes but we get a tiny glimpse into
her cheetah like powers as she makes a
giant leap into the sky as far as
footage goes this is actually one of the
best that we've seen so far most of the
footage that we've seen has had little
to no action in it and actually most of
the footage has just been gal gadot and
Chris Pine talking to each other so
compared to those this is actually kind
of decent nothing has really been given
to us concerning the plot of Wonder
Woman 1984 we know that Steve Trevor is
back but we have no idea how we know
that Kristen Wiig is playing cheetah but
we have no idea what the backstory of
cheetah is we have no idea how she gets
her powers and we have no idea where
she's from does she get her powers from
Earth cartagia is she brainwashed by the
terrorist organization Cobra there are
four main incarnations of cheetah in the
comics and there are many different
storylines we really haven't been given
any information on it but this video
does help it gives us our first glimpse
of Kristen Wiig as cheetah using her
powers and it's apparent that she can
use these powers without necessarily
transforming into a cheetah again
there's a lot that we don't know we
really don't know almost anything about
the plot but it is nice to see some
behind the scenes footage so there it is
the leaked video of Kristen Wiig as
cheetah on the set of Wonder Woman 1984
just wanted to get it out there so you
all could see it let me know your
thoughts on it and if you're excited to
see Wonder Woman 1984 in the common
below be sure to hit that thumbs up
button and subscribe to my channel so
you can stay up to date on one room in
1984 DC Marvel and all things superhero
thank you so much for watching woof woof
[Music]